alors à l'attaqué d'abord une heure à
les moteurs moi quand j'ai rencontré
thermale pour cette histoire mon
objectif c'était vraiment pas qu'ils
jouent dedans axiaux bonne chose même
pas imaginer mes deux s'étaient déjà
qu'il a jugé qu'elle qu'elle a un écho
chez lui après qu'il joue dedans ça a
été la cerise sur le gâteau toujours
d'aller bien
pourquoi farid shiloh chirurgie incluant
qui est un peu comme ça et comme cela
aussi l'esprit dit levy fils est
toujours aux aguets elle a toujours un
temps d'avancé
mais voilà il fait des petits troupeaux
siècle maroc'immo du gasoil etc et donc
je me suis beaucoup inspiré de cette
histoire de faire aussi pour créer le
personnage proclamé
notre époque on a un déficit malgré tout
ce qui concerne nos histoires les
histoires de nos parents c'est sur ce
voyage incroyable qu'ils ont fait notre
identité est mal raconté ou peut en tout
cas c'est mon père qui devait partir à
la france et ne suis pas moi une
opportunité d'avoir des visites et leurs
histoires jamais eu l'occasion d'en
parler véritablement avec kovalchuk
cette pudeur qui fait que ont condensé
peut finalement c'est ce que raconte ce
fils d'ailleurs vous avez maison là bas
une maison ici tempère il abandonne eu à
gérer depuis longtemps comme dans la
fameuse manita a construit une maison en
espérant que on y vivent tous un jour
plus tôt sans saveur avec une cabine du
coup d'une couche au jet set terre a
fait partie intégrante de nous j'ai
grandi un petit peu je suis retourné
tous les étés n'y a pas une année où je
m'en passe à au moins 15 jours au bled
connu là je suis en vacances si cet
amour pour le bled ça d'ailleurs pour
nos racines notamment pour notre culture
que nos parents qui ont fait qu'on on
s'y intéresse mon père cette maison
c'est tout ce qui lui reste ici mais
cette maison elle représente tous les
espoirs de nos parents pas les nôtres
ici chez toi
écrasé par les 150 pas chez 100
personnes dormant
je réfléchis à deux les assurances